[Musique]
si les investisseurs ne viennent que
pour avoir accès aux meilleures
technologies sans que ça puisse profiter
ni à la france ni à aucun autre pays
européen
mais ils ne sont pas les bienvenus
fabien ivaïlo jeannie longo partir et
moi georges éthier
[Musique]
vous avez vous aux intérêts stratégiques
nous comprenons très bien mais nous
français nous avons aussi nos intérêts
stratégiques
[Musique]
mon
et l'initiative des routes de la soie
que vous avez proposé au monde monsieur
le président est un geste extrêmement
structurants qui peut contribuer à la
stabilité et au développement à la
coexistence pacifique entre les peuples
[Musique]
mais gare aux chutes at the cost of
early show marge trop d'ailleurs que le
tuning est doux et villagrains dans la
courte ligne de politique arabe aux
mines de gaz de charbon et bana vous et
villagrains d'énergie alors qu'est ce
qui n'a qu'à se réfère à l'entretenir 5
2009 à qu'adapter chenil faux voyez
vous-même 20 juillet justin krueger
colomba niche macro tard au rugby bat
causés par west a fait la menthe ou 2
lits ou de like you
[Musique]
constructive au contraire les
proportions inquiétantes au made in
china kevin in italia est trop pop rock
made in italy kéba in china
[Musique]
on
toyoda vienne pour y charger nos phobies
être à 100%